I was posting these things saying it
doesn't bother me because I didn't want
it to bother other people who are
experiencing the same thing Selena Gomez
explains why she feels the need to lie
about the hate she receives on social
media I'm very honest though in General
on the Apple TV Plus show deer the
actress opens up about being body shamed
following Her diagnosis with lupus my
weight would constantly fluctuate as I
would be on certain medications
and obviously people just ran with it it
was like they couldn't wait to find a
thing to bring me down
I was being shamed for gaining weight
because of my lupus and as a result
Selena would pretend those rude comments
didn't bother her like when she posted
this video after the 2023 Golden Globes
I'm a little bit big right now because I
enjoyed myself during the holidays I was
posting these things saying it doesn't
bother me because I didn't want it to
bother other people who are experiencing
the same thing I would go online and I
would post a picture of myself and I
would say it doesn't matter
I'm not accepting what you're saying
all the while being in the room posting
not crying my eyes off because nobody
deserves to hear those things on social
media it's as much as it's a blessing
and it's fun it it can really tear
people down and I always hope that the
people I'm involved with or support me
can just kind of spread love within that
this comes just two weeks after cell
announced she's taking the social media
break because
it's this is a little silly
and I'm 30. I'm too old for this I'm
good I love who I am I don't care I'm
big I'm not I would I don't I don't care
I love who I am why well it all started
because of a rumored online feud between
cell Kylie Jenner and Haley Bieber who's
married to cell's X Justin Bieber and
things only got worse when this clip
resurfaced Haley gagging At The Mention
Of Taylor Swift sells long time bestie
on drop the Mike Hollywood's top Stars
face off in a one-on-one rap battle full
of the meanest lyrics about a celebrity
since Taylor Swift's last album
Selena defended Taylor in the comments
writing so sorry my best friend is and
continues to be one of the best in the
game and after a whole Firestorm of
commentary online it was time for SG to
pump the brakes and I will see you guys
um sooner than later I just I'm gonna
just take a break from everything I'm at
that age where I feel like that's what
matters is making sure I'm healthy and
people are happy that I love sells
returned a couple of times since
revealing her social media Hiatus
including sharing moments with her
family like these pics from a boat day
with her stepdad Brian and younger
sister Gracie I'm really happy place
it's been good
[Music]